p d'abord le match du week-end sur le
ring des meetings c'était le pen contre
émouvant famille arik air
ils étaient 6000 samedi à lille venus
applaudir eric zemmour 4000 à reims le
même jour au meeting de marine le pen un
duel à distance oppose les deux rivaux
d'extrême droite devant ses militants la
présidente du rassemblement national a
mis en avant sa personnalité et son
expérience ils ont ni les embuscades ni
les manoeuvres je n'ai comme boussole
que l'intérêt supérieur de notre pays et
de notre peuple marine le pen fragilisé
par les récentes défections dans ses
rangs au profit du camp seymour son
entourage le reconnaît eric zemmour peut
barrer la route du second tour à leur
candidate et c'est pour ça qu'il ne peut
pas aller au second tour mais il sait et
c'est peut-être son objectif qu'il peut
faire battre marine le pen peut-être que
c'est davantage son objectif pour demain
reconstituer une espèce de partis de
droite d'union des droits de côté pour
eric zemmour aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans les sondages a fait bien la
candidature de marine le pen c'est
évidemment risqué en second tour et
creysse macro quelques jours plus tôt la
présidente du fn avait violemment
attaqué son rival dans une interview au
figaro accusant l'entourage d'eric
zemmour d'héberger quelques nazis ce
matin le candidat lui a répondu il n'y a
pas de nazi dans mon équipe il faut
arrêter avec cette insulte qui est
d'abord que j'ai prise à la légère parce
qu'elle est tellement idiote que je ne
les ai pas prises au sérieux mais
maintenant ça suffit parce que je pense
qu'il faut arrêter ce cirque de son côté
eric zemmour a déroulé samedi un
discours contre l'assistanat et
d'immigration à 63 jours du premier tour
les deux candidats se retrouvent au
coude à coude dans l'opinion un sondage
publié dimanche les données à égalité
des intentions de vote et on débat
autour de cette guerre des droites avec
alexia germond bonsoir bienvenue soit
vous êtes président de formatrice du
think tank la france audacieuse d'un
fondatrice c'est ce que et fondatrice et
parfois triste ça commence bien ce débat
non excusez moi donc fondatrice du think
tank france audacieuse y arriver
reaktion bonsoir ça va être facile
directeur de la rédaction de l'express
les toubon chouette je progresse jérôme
savary bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sondeurs politologues président de
l'institut pôle inbox et vous publiez je
le rappelle bloc populaire une
subversion électorale inachevé c'est aux
éditions du cerf bonsoir matthieu
croissandeau vaut surtout analyse
politique bienvenues comme tous les
lundis et mercredis dans cette émission
rappelle d
des meetings et du nombre de
participants on l'a vu dans le sujet à
l'instant 6000 personnes à lille avec
eric zemmour 4000 à reims pour marine le
pen alexeï guerman est ce qu'il a pour
autant remporter se rendent eric zemmour
le six mois j'étais sur le ring du
week-end est ce que ça suffit le nombre
de le nombre de participants ou est-ce
que c'est l'image ou la phrase qui
frappe non je n'aurais pas dit que
c'était le grand vainqueur du week end
il me semble que par sa séquence qui
n'était pas sur le fond mais sur la
forme plus intimiste de marine le pen
l'objectif a été atteint c'est à dire
qu'on a parlé que de ça en fin de
week-end mettant de côté finalement
l'organisation
il faut quand même voir 6000 personnes
dans une salle c'est quand même pas mal
aujourd'hui d'arriver à rassembler
autant de monde alors on comprend bien
pourquoi parce que derrière il y a quand
même tous les réseaux de sens commun qui
sont aguerris à ce genre d'exercice qui
savent très bien mobilisés dans des
temps record donc on voit bien l'écurie
cas cités et d'un point de vue général
même sur la façon dont ces meetings sont
organisées on voit quand tout cas eric
zemmour pour un nouveau venu a su
s'entourer de gens qui savent faire bon
marine le pen c'est pas parce qu'elle
avait deux mille personnes de moins qu'
il n'y avait personne non plus dans dans
la salle donc je crois qu'il faut
reprendre aussi un peu de la mesure par
rapport aux choses et que ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi de regarder sur
le fond ce qui les différencie ce qui
les rassemble et est ce que ça peut
donner après alors justement est-ce
qu'ils ont le même bassin d'électeurs
beaucoup plus subtil pas vraiment un
tout petit mot comme sur les sondages
moi je suis un peu surpris de l'écho que
ce sondage ipsos mené tout seul à dire a
donné ses résultats d'égalité j'ai
regardé c'est égalité entre eux eric
zemmour et marine le pen voilà c'est pas
du tout ce que disent les deux rowling
publié aujourd'hui celui de l'ifop vient
juste de tomber ça donne plutôt 14 à
eric zemmour 17 à marine le pen et
pécresse à peu près à 16 et je crois que
là dans le lot l'ifop vient de tomber ce
soir on sait qu'en suisse moi je suis ça
les joueurs forcément je crois que là
c'est trois points d'écart également 14
5 et 17 5 mai alors que c'est stable
dans l'autre rowling là c'est tout le
monde nous remonter plus tôt d'eric
zemmour donc ya pas de si vous vous
laissez
c'était 2d cammas est importante et
surtout quand vous regardez second tour
il faudra qu'on en parle là vous avez un
écart très important
eric zemmour n'a jamais réussi à
atteindre 40% donc il ne peut pas et ne
peut pas tenir une promesse de victoires
à ses électeurs ses électeurs alors sur
les militants d'après ce que j'ai lu
puis après ce qu'on m'a raconté entre
lille et reims il y avait une différence
très creusée c'est à dire qu'à reims
c'était très populaire inversement à
lille c'était plus comme on voit souvent
d'ailleurs chez les jeunes autour de
zemmour s'était davantage des beaux
quartiers radicaliser et si je veux dire
c'est un peu les enfants de fillon mais
qui sont saisis par la débauche et vous
ensuite sur les électorats là c'est plus
nuancé dire qu'effectivement marine le
pen a une influence une hégémonie très
forte dans les milieux populaires
notamment je fais ça les salariés
pauvres du privé alors qu'elle est
faible chez les retraités donc elle
s'est vraiment il ya un véritable vote
de classe qui s'expriment en faveur de
marine le pen mal a du mal à sortir
effectivement de cette population
ouvriers employés petit indépendant
c'est quand même 50 % la population
active n'oublions pas enfin c'est vrai
qu'à l'animal de sortir de là de ses
soutiens au gilet jaune qu'on pourrait
dire les choses rapidement pour eric
zemmour est là un électorat qui est pas
tellement cheap et c'est à dire que les
foules dans les différentes csp s'est à
peu près stable il a une meilleure
pénétration électorale parmi les
retraités et puis comme chacun sait il a
rêvé riffier quelque chose qui avait
disparu la sociologie électorale c'est à
dire les jaunards cap et puisque
effectivement il a nettement plus de
votes parmi les hommes que parmi les
femmes ou beaucoup moins chez les femmes
on va vous avez fait référence à cette
séquence assez
intimiste dans le meeting de de marine
le pen je vous propose de voir un
extrait je vous donne la parole juste
après
marine le beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous
les ponts
j'ai beaucoup appris j'étais en tournée
j'ai parfois échoué je suis tombé je me
suis toujours relevé
pour reprendre vos la lumineuse formule
d'aidé sans demander là je n'ai jamais
perdu soit j'ai gagné soit j'ai pris
alors
je vais présente devant vous devant les
français pour la fonction suprême je
suis prête je sais pas comment nelson
mandela aurait réagi en entendant marine
le pen le site et bref eric chelle c'est
sa troisième campagne à marine le pen
est ce qu elle a encore besoin de se
faire connaître des français ou est ce
que je vais dire une séquence comme
celle là on pourrait dire aller au real
car valérie pécresse en a besoin parce
que c'est sa première campagne pour
qu'elle fonde l'armure mais est-ce que
marine le pen en a encore devant elle a
besoin de tous parce que c'est très
simple en 2017 elle échoue donc elle a
forcément besoin de quelque chose en
nous de se faire connaître ce qu'on
disait pendant très longtemps s'aggraver
besoin d'avoir de se re crédibiliser sur
ses promesses etc mais ça ne suffit pas
elle a besoin à partir du moment et
c'est ce qu'elle avait pas escompté
maintenant qu'elle a en face d'elle un
vrai concurrent avec dire examu re elle
a besoin de faire une différence et
cette différence elle va la chercher
notamment dans l'incarnation et l'a
finalement c'est presque un coup de com
ce qu'elle a fait d'ailleurs si on n'en
parle pas maintenant parce que la
réussite à créer une sorte de mini
événement ou d'un coup en allant qu'on
joue en la personnalisation très forte
et ses enfants ne s'est pas tout à fait
nouveau on l'a vu en deux mois avec
cette émission où elles se livraient
elle même elle est dans une année où
elle va se livrer à la fois en tant que
femme en tant que personne elle va
montrer ses failles et le joue sur ses
failles en fait elle a envie de dire la
france est abîmée moi aussi j'ai été
abîmée à d'autres moments dans mon
parcours depuis d'ailleurs depuis mon
enfance et voyez finalement il ya
quelque chose dans la france et dans moi
qui peuvent faire écho et je pense que
c'est cette carte-là qui avait calé en
train de jouer oui bien sûr qu'on la
connaît mais enfin ce qu'on connaît
c'est elle ça a été plutôt le côté la
fille de son père et puis cette
tentative de diabolisation de
dédiabolisation qu'elle est en train
d'essayer de faire maintenant autrement
jusqu'à citer quand même effectivement
ben nelson mandela là on rêve
une des candidates qui a le plus tiré
les leçons de cette défaite de 2017
quand vous regardez jean luc mélenchon
par exemple il a perdu garde le même
programme gars du même candidat et puis
voilà ils aménagent à la marge marine le
pen elle a changé programmatiquement l'a
fait sur la question de l'euro l'a fait
sur la question de schengen et l'a fait
sur la question des retraites elle a
pris une forme du virage écologiste qui
ferait hurler les écologistes mais en
tout cas elle parle d'écologie alors
qu'elle n'apparaît pas avant et puis
elle sait aussi que dans cette défaite
de 2007 il fait une équation personnelle
qui était sa personnalité à elle sa
personne ses capacités ses capacités à
gouverner à se crédibiliser donc là
entamé un travail je pas certain que les
français encore imprimés et puis qui
était au fond c'est pas nouveau ce
qu'elle raconte l'a déjà dit dans des
émissions tout tout tout tout ce qu'elle
a raconté que ce soit l'attentât de 1976
au domicile familial que ce soit le
divorce de ses parents que ce soit la
façon dont elle a élevé ses enfants tout
seuls elle avait déjà raconté mais elle
est dans une dans un processus
d'humanisation s'est elle veut plus être
l'épouvantail d'extrême droite mais
quelqu'un qui est capable d'être plus
rond d'être plus maternant si j'ose dire
c'est un virage quand même amusant parce
qu'elle avait déjà tenté en 2016 en
lançant une affiche qui n'avait pas duré
très longtemps qui s'appelait la france
apaisée elle est déçue déjà sur ce
créneau là et puis elle l'avait remise
et parce que j'ai trouvé que c'était pas
assez cinglant voyez une phrase qui me
revient c'est c'est celle de jean marie
le pen qui disait un front national
gentis l'intérêt de personne c'était
l'époque où il était il voulait être le
réceptacle des colères on voit bien que
marine le pen l'a fait un pas de côté ne
veut plus seulement être le réceptacle
de des colères mais veut pouvoir fédérer
un peu plus autour d'elle mais et dans
la saga familiale d'aidé le pen ya des
coups bas des trahisons des victoires
aussi et la voix du patriarche elle
continue de se faire entendre c'était le
3 février jean-marie le pen et alors il
il était face aux journées de l' effet
il soutient sa fille et en même temps il
tresse des lauriers à eric zemmour
écouter ouais le soutien à marine le pen
d'abord parce qu'elle est la candidate
officielle
soutenu par le mouvement national
par le rassemblement national
ensuite parce qu'elle me paraît hors
fait l'effort de réparations nécessaires
et qu'elle a maintenant la dimension
d'une candidate à la présidence de la
république tout à fait de l'importante
examen est un garçon qu'il ya comme
qualités intellectuelles
morales
que c'est un ami donc quand
je le regarde ces initiatives avec
sympathie sans pour autant être un
électeur acquis à l'extérieur mons et le
nom le pen pour marine le pen c'est à la
fois un atout et une faiblesse
aujourd'hui oui bah on voit bien
d'ailleurs sur les dernières affiches
qui sont sortis le nom le pen
n'existent plus donc ça a été
complètement complètement rayé je crois
que effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est celle qui a été capable de
démontrer la plus grande résilience qui
en même temps est obligé d'assumer son
héritage ce qu'elle a fait dans la
partie dite plus intimiste moi je trouve
c'est très personnel mais je vous livre
quand même ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
ressenti quand pendant le meeting j'ai
trouvé que s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
séquence qui avait intéressé sur le fond
c'était un meeting très très moyen hmm
hmm je vais dire dans la séquence arts
oratoires parce qu'on a quand même
affaire à quelqu'un qui est une vraie
politique qui s'est autant eric zemmour
avait une large marge de progression
ce qu'il a d'ailleurs été capable de
rattraper relativement rapidement avec
des échéances importantes
elles très curieusement elle a été
obligée de parler fort elle était
beaucoup plus vindicative donc c'était
aussi en deux seins des dernières
positions des derniers positionnement
qu'elle nous avait montré à la
télévision où on avait une marine le pen
tout à fait en rondeur et en douceur qui
tente de rassurer parce que derrière ce
que vous disiez eric c'est sain c'est en
fait elle a besoin de rassurer et sur la
compétence pour le débat raté qui est
quand même quelque chose qu'il faut
qu'il faut porter et dont il faut savoir
se relever et puis en même temps elle a
besoin de montrer qu'elle à
l'incarnation potentiel qu'elles se
dédiabolise mais aussi tisser ce lien
tout particulier avec les français et ça
fait le lien finalement avec ce qui est
devant elle pour valérie pécresse alors
c'est un match à trois évidemment si on
regarde un peu les les sondages depuis
plusieurs mois on voit une valérie
pécresse qui est à 10% avant sa victoire
au congrès elle monte jusqu'à 17% elle
décolle pas vraiment marine le pen fait
le yoyo entre 14 et 16 eric zemmour
entre 13
et 16 alors on est sûr on a on a choisi
un seul institut
et c'est ipsos alors vous seriez en
train de critiquer jérôme sainte-marie
leurs derniers sondages qui
effectivement place place valérie
pécresse légèrement devant et les deux
les deux suivants à égalité mais en fait
on a l'impression que c'est un un
phénomène de vases communicants de lui
depuis plusieurs mois la sauce a choisi
une méthode de sélection des interviewés
très particulier précisément une
l'assiette sur laquelle ils font leurs
intentions de vote c'est à partir d'une
sélection très dur en termes de
certitude d'aller voter c'est en fait
sur un axe est la nôtre disco grosso
modo ça a des conséquences politiques
immédiates c'est que vous avez tendance
à se représenter les csp + et les gens
diplômés ils vont intégrer et cetera
mais donc ça profite naturellement
donc c'est un institut tout à fait
sérieuses ont fait ce choix
méthodologiques des skins fine et c'est
eux qui auront raison mais je constate
que c'est des chiffres qui sont tout à
fait différent de tous les autres
instituts l'ascension d'eric zemmour qui
est enfin elle donne vie à cinq six mois
quand même hein
cette espèce de d'irruption dans la
campagne c'est à une et un moment où
forcément la cristallisation allez on en
est très très très loin est ce que au
fur et à mesure que la cristallisation
des voilà du choix des électeurs ce fait
est ce que ça le dessert finale alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir que on
a trois forces trois personnalités qui
sont finalement il ya des différences
entre instituts mais à la fin des fins
et quand même il ya trois points entre
le premier et le troisième donc c'est le
match n'est pas fait alors il ya des
choses très intéressantes il ya des
plusieurs paradoxes de primes paradoxe
par rapport à marine le pen elle est
aujourd'hui une des personnalités les
plus appréciées des français dans
l'institut bbva qui mesure 38
personnalité quand même un dans le
baromètre de l'image elle est deuxième
des choses qui est même d'ailleurs
l'arrivée d'eric zemmour a plutôt
redresser son image par rapport à
septembre donc et ce pendant lé patient
être qualifié au second tour
et après un autre un autre paradoxe et
pour eric zemmour il arrive avec une
formule qui suppose gagnante pour le
camp nationaliste on va dire enfin
l'union des droites marine le pen peut
pas y arriver etc or les sondages se
suivent et se ressemblent pour lui sur
le second tour il n'arrive pas même pas
à la barre des 40%
rires ça ne marche pas sa solution ça me
va marcher pour 2000 2022 au point
d'ailleurs autour de lui on parle de
plus en plus la recomposition après
l'échec de mai van de vyver tout avoir
et pourtant il ne s'effondre pas on
pourrait se dire bon ben voilà il est à
sa fille marché en en septembre octobre
après bon elle a perdu 2,3 points mais
là il même un institut où il remonte et
cetera donc ça ne s'effondrait pas donc
la touche est véritablement une culture
il y a il est et comment il régit la
reconstituer n'ont pas lu non à droite
mais en constituer une droite voilà et
pour valérie pécresse alors là il ya
moins de paradoxes et j'en suis désolé
diana quand même c'est que alors qu'elle
vient d'un parti qui est qui a plutôt
remporté les départementales et les
régionales un grand parti de
gouvernement gala une image personnelle
qui n'est pas mauvaise et cetera au
second tour elle fait à peine deux
points de plus face à macro que marine
le pen et le ps c'est inconcevable
encore une fois donc la notion de
profondes vers un petit peu voler en
éclats parce que là on voit plus ça et
que l alors là c'est paradoxal co2 en
deux de toute considération sur sa
personne pour sa campagne elle a une
difficulté structurelle c'est qu'une
bonne partie de ces électeurs potentiels
ont une bonne image des manuels macro
donc elle se présente contre un
président sortant sans pouvoir mais
s'opposer de manière trop clair parce
que sinon 30 à 50% sont les tournées les
deux sens les périodes des anciens
électeurs fillon ont soutenus macron
durant le quinquennat effectivement dans
ce match à trois
eric chelle faut parler du quatrième
homme quoi qui est accessoirement repris
dans la ville c'est vrai que ça change
un peu tout bas oui en particulier vous
prenez prenez valérie pécresse n'attend
qu'une chose puisque depuis maintenant
longtemps elle s'est mis en situation de
dire je serai dans un duel avec emmanuel
macron bah oui mais on a dû l on est 2e
et là il est prié toujours pas là donc
en fait elle se bat un peu dans le vide
depuis plusieurs semaines en attendant
son arrivée son arrivée on sait dans les
prochains jours enfin on pense
maintenant on a l'impression quand même
ça fait dix jours pour 10 et dans les
prochains jours oui là il ya une crise
voir ce qu'il en est ce qui se passe et
puis suite à un agenda dans les
prochains jours où commencent les
rumeurs enflent voilà effectivement à
partir du moment où il va rentrer sur le
ring là je pense qu'on aura à peu près
quand même tous les candidats et là tout
d'un coup on verra peut-être davantage
cette cristallisation ou le moment ce
que je constate c'est qu'effectivement
c'est vrai que c'est très intéressant de
voir ces trois de ces trois personnages
de droite de droite et puis moi je dis
les deux autres quand même d'extrême
droite par la même chose est ce que ce
qui est vrai qu'ils tiennent à deux ou
trois points on a vu des tendances
depuis trois mois on a vu après la
primaire valérie pécresse à un niveau
élevé on a cru un moment khaled à
redescendre et on voit dans les tout
derniers sondages en fait elle reste
sans arriver à monter mais au fond il
n'y a pas non plus reflux est allé aux
alentours de 16 17 selon les instituts
on a cru aussi de la même façon que eric
zemmour salle est une bulle
et que cette bulle allait sans doute
éclaté gars de trois mois et qu'il
allait peut-être passer sous les 10
tonnes façon disent non seulement il
s'est tenu mais même on le voit
effectivement maintenant on voit les
efforts qui fait depuis un mois ou un
mois et demi en communication en meeting
son meeting à cannes à des pics et des
gens chez eux chez chez marine le pen
tout ça finit par lui apporter à points
deux points de plus donc en fait
aujourd'hui on est quand même c'est
impossible aujourd'hui de savoir qui
dans les trois va réussir à monter sur
la 2e marche et ensuite partir du moment
où on aura effectivement les deux
personnes je suis incapable aujourd'hui
de faire confiance à ce qui nous est dit
sur le deuxième tour ça me paraît
totalement improbable
la buse d'abord la la la non mais vu la
configuration actuelle la confirmation a
complètement changé on voit une marine
le pen allait faire ses courses je
dirais aussi d'un électorat de gauche ya
plus de gauche aujourd'hui a disparu est
là il n'y a plus aujourd'hui c'est elle
qui porte une parole de social et
opportune forum social le plus en plus
fort si vous entendez toutes les mesures
qu'elle propose vous dire s'ils ont eu à
peine de gauche il ya notre notre
communiste qui lui aussi a bien saisi le
fait que la gauche devait être sur le
social l'ocab 2 aujourd'hui candidats
qui se sont mis sur ce terrain là il ya
le candidat communiste et puis à marine
le pen fabien roussel mais on n'est pas
là pour pelles et de la gauche mais
puisqu'on l'a déjà fait en juin mais
calme un discours très clair sur la
laïcité ou si c'est pas de train dans
sur la petite musique positive autour de
sa complicité et une nationalisation des
banques et des assurances n'est pas non
plus de truies ça reste un candidat
communiste rami et d'un autre côté
emmanuel macron qui on sait pas lui
lorsqu'il va sortir du bois s'il va
tomber plutôt à gauche ou plutôt à
droite et effectivement il a réussi à
embarquer beaucoup d'électeurs de
françois fillon ces électeurs là vont
ils faire confiance suffisamment à
valérie pécresse pour revenir se déroule
dans le camp d'où il était auparavant ou
alors se dire finalement on est bien
chez manuel macro d'autant plus qu'il ya
quand même des anciens de chez l air qui
sont aujourd'hui proches de macron
madame aime beaucoup alors on va
proposer à steve jourdain de nous
rejoindre ce qu'on va faire là tout de
suite continué de faire un zoom sur la
campagne de valérie pécresse bonsoir si
on sarthois bienvenue heureux de vous
accueillir sur sur ce plateau on l'a
évoqué valérie pécresse parti très fort
juste après l'investiture du congrès
l'air et cette impression que ça
ronronne un peu que oui alors il ya les
sondages vous connaissez la petite
musique un ça va ça vient c'est comme je
vous laisse terminer la queue du chien
mais les équipes de valérie pécresse
reconnaissent un quand même qu'il ya
actuellement un problème valérie
pécresse qui a actuellement un faux plat
dans sa campagne un faux plat ça
ressemble à quoi thomas ça ressemble à
ça souvenez vous après la primaire a
l'air vous le disiez valérie pécresse
était dans certains sondages donnait
gagnante face à emmanuel macron au
second tour aujourd'hui elle se
hisserait péniblement au second tour
elle stagne en tout cas selon les
différents instituts est à noël stagne
autour de 15 16% alors valérie pécresse
fait vraiment campagne elle est vraiment
sur le terrain
vraiment sur les plateaux de télé mais
elle ne prime pas vraiment dans
l'opinion alors pourquoi ça eh bien vous
posez la question à rachida dati rachida
dati qui a toujours un peu de mal avec
la langue de bois rachida dati qui sent
la sulfateuse dans le figaro la semaine
dernière jeudi l'ancien garde des sceaux
qui dit la chose suivante l'alignement
des propositions ne peut apparaître
comme une posture technocratique
l'élection présidentielle c'est avant
tout la rencontre d'un homme ou d'une
femme avec le peuple français pas avec
une somme de propositions a bonne
entendeur thomas pierre dans le jardin
de valérie pécresse qui a quand même une
équation assez difficile à résoudre oui
comment faire revenir au bercail
l'électorat de françois fillon françois
fillon le rappel en 2017 c'est tout de
même 20 % au premier tour et le problème
est bien c'est que cet électorat est
écartelé selon un sondage ipsos les plus
de 7 6 millions de français qui ont voté
sion à la dernière élection pencherait
aujourd'hui ac 56% pour valérie pécresse
1 22% pour emmanuel macron
pas moi 22% pour emmanuel macron à 20%
pour eric zemmour et 2% de 4% pour
marine le pen dans l'entourage de
valérie texas on nous dit que ceux qui
pêchent actuellement c'est le domaine du
régalien il faut qu'elle muscle son jeu
sur les domaines de l'international de
la justice confort la sécurité des
thèmes qui sont actuellement accaparé
par emmanuel macron et par l'extrême
droite un rendez vous important a noté
thomas sur ceux sur ceux sur cette
campagne de valérie pécresse et ce
dimanche le 13 février valérie pécresse
qui organise son tout premier grand
meeting de campagne c'est au zénith à
paris peut-être l'occasion de muscler un
peu son jeu justement et de hausser le
ton merci beaucoup merci steve pour pour
toutes ces informations et cette analyse
je vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
valérie pécresse était
hier sur france 5 elle est sur la
question de l'identité française on
écoute si je me rends dans un pays arabe
je me rendrai tête nous pousserait pas
je serai pas voilée parce que la
république française
elle elle s'identifie à l'identité
française est l'identifiant ça c'est une
femme qui ne porte pas de voile donc je
pense que déjà c'est c'était quelque
chose d'assez puissant que le la
présidente française soit une femme et
qu'elle ne soit pas voilées matthieu
croissandeau parce que tu amusant c'est
que juste après une spécialiste une
experte sur deux sur le plateau qu'il
n'y a plus de pays arabes qui impose aux
robots ou visites étrangères qui
représentent la ligne à porter le voile
c'est un non débat là ils répondent tant
mieux oui si on reste sur l'analyse de
la campagne de valérie pécresse alyssa
germond si vous le disais à l'instant il
ya son meeting dimanche prochain bon
alors c'est toujours une analyse qu'on
fait
dix jours trois semaines ou trois mois
après où avec le recul peut y avoir un
meeting tournant dans une dans une
campagne est ce que vous diriez que là
on est quand même on sera deux mois de
la
moine de moi même puisque c'est jeudi du
premier tour parce que là c'est
maintenant qu'il faut que quelqu'un
parmi ces semis simla et c'est pas après
le meeting c'est clair parce que
valérie pécresse n'a pas besoin de
montrer plus de légitimité sur les
dossiers on voit bien à chaque fois
qu'elle est que ça soit en débat où elle
va dans le fond des sujets c'est une
femme qui connaît ses dossiers donc ce
point là est réglé il y à une question
de positionnement politique qui est un
quand même essentiel et steve jourdain
ne l'expliqué bien parce que c'est
finalement les deux les branches du
compas ou une grand etc à vous exprimer
ça comme vous voulez mais ça va du
centre droite jusque à des positions
extrêmement forte sur le régalien qui
est d'ailleurs très bien incarnée par
des spécialistes du sujet parce que vous
avez évidemment patrick stefanini vous
avez également thibault de montbrial mon
confrère et ami qui qui est très en
soutien sur cette partie là bon donc on
voit bien que sur le fond des sujets il
ya des arbitrages à faire avec une
difficulté et en même temps qu'était sa
force c'est qu'elle a quand même réussi
à garder l'unité de la famille politique
ce qui n'était pas gagné 1 à la la
sortie de la primaire et puis après il
ya toute la question plus personnelle et
sur la question plus personnelle c'est
que alors on parle beaucoup de
l'incarnation
bien sûr c'est là qu'il faut à un moment
rentrer dans le jeu et une faut donner
envie aux français faut parler collectif
faut quitter les techniques il faut
avoir cette cet élan ce souffle et en
meeting vous êtes à la fois porter mais
il faut savoir faire parce que on voit
bien que eric zemmour a fait de son il
partait de loin aussi un sourd passer
les messages
les vidéos qu'on avait de la convention
de la droite avec marion maréchal-le pen
s'était pas un orateur né et c'est dans
ces fiches aulas il ya eu un vrai
travail c'est pas anecdotique parce que
vous n'êtes capable de faire parler
votre coeur que si tout le reste ou le
back-office est vraiment vraiment bien
bien maîtrisée en fête est donc là pour
valérie pécresse il faut qu'elle incarne
il faut qu'elle donne envie et il faut
qu'elles trouvent
une phrase ou en tout cas un axe qui
fasse que elle est identifiée est
aujourd'hui le seul axe qui ressort
c'est peut-être l'histoire du karcher
kane qui a qui avait que 1 pendant une
semaine dix jours mais pardon d'être
direct mais l'histoire du karcher c'est
un retour
dans le temps passer et c'est parce
qu'on demande à une présidentielle ce
qu'on veut à une présidentielle c'est
nous projeter vers l'avenir s'est
embarqué les troupes et les troupes sont
là et c'est ce que vous c'est ce que
vous disiez parce que finalement il y a
avec valérie pécresse un vrai parti de
gouvernement un vrai maillage
territorial il y à des équipes des
militants sur place des élus donc il y a
tout sur le papier et la difficulté
qu'elle a aujourd'hui c'est que vous à
part le kärcher qui était plus
anecdotique finalement ce qu'elle m'aime
beaucoup pas en avant qu'est ce que
c'est c'est je suis la seule à pouvoir
battre emmanuel macron deuxième tour où
second tour mais si ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres ne disent
pas qu'elle a raison donc il faut
arriver il ya de la marge encore donc il
faut arriver très vite à crantée
sur quelque chose qu'ils identifient
qu'ils fassent quand même temps sa
notoriété puisse aussi augmenté parce
qu'elle est très connue évidemment en
région ile de france je pense qu'elle
est respectée pour le travail qu'elle
qu'elle est capable qu'elle a démontrée
et on voit tout le potentiel qu'il y a
mais
il faut qu'elle s'impose comme étant ce
que j'appelle la chef quoi la chef de
meute et surtout à droite ça compte
c'est ce positionnement là on va
consacrer un chapitre à la prêt à la
recomposition des droites mais quand
même je voudrais rebondir ce que vous
disiez sur le les incertitudes liées aux
sondages et notamment au second tour
jérôme sainte-marie quand on voit
finalement le peu d'écart entre les
trois candidats déclarés de la droite et
où et ou de l'extrême droite on est
presque dans la marge d'erreur
dans tous les cas non sur le premier
tour oui sur le premier tour bien sûr on
est quasiment la marge d'erreur n'est
pas entre la première une troisième
quand même hein si l'on en croit pour
les autres instituts mais bon en plus
chez les mouvements tous les jours ça un
rolling etc les choses peuvent quelqu'un
peut décrocher donc là pour l'instant
eric zemmour lui vise électorale par les
pécresse le taureau de marine le pen à
une telle cote comment dirais-je
stabilité sociologique le problème pour
elle de savoir si vous c'est son night
tour avalée voter ou pas mais c'est pas
tellement et pas tellement il ya plus
d'élément d'activité chez eric zemmour
qui en plus un programme de plus en plus
ultralibérales c'est l'information de
week-end c'est que sa radicalisation est
aussi une radicalisation en libéral et
lire les l'histoire des primes
dont chargée ça signifie quand même
assez rapidement je pensais dominique ce
qu'il a écrit tout de suite c'est assez
rapidement ça signifie quand même que la
sécurité sociale et l'état s'en vont
alors se ressource à sécher non que
c'est vraiment ça c'est un choix très
particulier et donc lui il va du côté de
l'ancien électorat fillon et donc il va
disputer sa à valérie pécresse bon ce
qui n'est pas dans la marge d'erreur
c'est le second tour le second tour on a
quand vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec avec
ce que ce que nous n'aurions nous disait
ne pas être d'accord c'est ça signifie
quelque chose ces équilibres de second
tour vous savez ils ont annoncé
généralement les changements qu'elle est
avoir lieu un que ce soit pour nicolas
sarkozy
en 2000 à partir de janvier 2007 est
donné gagnant au second tour il va
l'emporter en 2012 étaient donnés battus
ils étaient battus et c'est donc les
gens c'est assez simple quand même pour
les gens ne soient représentés cela ça
peut évoluer mais il ya deux
informations à mon avis importante c'est
que dans ces trois droites il y en a
deux qui ont une chance
quand j'ai une chance c'est pas grave
c'est vraisemblable que c'est possible
de l'emporter face à emmanuel macron
c'est valérie pécresse et marine le pen
quand vous êtes autour de 45% dans une
campagne qui va être très courte ça peut
se faire peut probablement on a un autre
entre 37 et 39 % au second tour là c'est
à peu près au minimum ses 22 points
d'écart quand même par rapport à macron
c'est compliqué d'autant plus que ces
chiffres là sont à mettre en relation
avec les traits d'image que l'on mesure
dans d'autres sondages dans la presse et
on voit que alors que l'image voir les
pécresse est assez bonne et a pas
tellement bougé salle de marine le pen
s'est améliorée sans traduction
électorale de premier tour pour
l'instant celle de moore a été et
demeure extrêmement négative hier vous
avez eu récemment un sondage ifop où on
a testé les ils ont testé les 3
candidats de 3 droite justement à trois
candidats de droite selon différents
critères le seul où eric zemmour fait la
différence 55% alors qu'on est ici ça se
partage avec valérie pécresse avec
marine le pen et avec au cocan cela seul
vous ferrez différents 55% c'est vous
inquiète mais ce que je veux dire marine
le pen est à 9,1 sur ce critère là et
inversement sur tous les autres traits
d'image y compris quand on parle des
français en général mais même des
électeurs de la droite radicale où
l'ensemble de la droite il est devant
c'est donc ce sera au tour qui est très
négatif pour lui correspond un des
traits d'image très négatif allez on se
projette maintenant mathieu dans dans l'
après la recomposition des droites à
l'horizon post présidentielle les
républicains selon vous il souffle de il
souffre de problèmes sont beaucoup plus
profond que ce qu'ils veulent laisser
paraître oui je pense que la droite est
dans un sale état alors ça peut paraître
provocateur parce qu en apparence tout
va bien comme vous le disiez c'est vrai
qu'ils sont rassemblés qu'ils ont connu
des succès électoraux ces deux dernières
années aux municipales aux régionales ou
départementales
ils ont une candidate qui a été désigné
au terme d'un congrès qui s'est plutôt
bien passé et puis les sondages qui la
donnent en capacité de se qualifier
quand même pour le second tour et
pourtant moins chauve qui a un côté
village potemkine d'abord parce qu'il ya
un vide programmatique on se demande
qu'a fait la droite depuis cinq ans elle
a pansé ses plaies c'est vrai la compter
les défections dans le camp vaincrons
mais du point de vue du contenu je
trouve ça très frappant elle a beaucoup
de mal à faire émerger de nouvelles
idées elle a été siphonné sur le plan
économique par emmanuel macron lé
confiance et sur le plan sécuritaire par
marine le pen eric zemmour et du coup
elle se réfugie comme vous le disiez
dans le passé à ce titre ses gammes
assez instructif de voir que valérie
pécresse a commencé sa campagne en
invoquant les mânes de margaret thatcher
et quand même quitté le pouvoir en 1990
c'est donc il ya 32 ans non mais ça en
dit long sur le public cible quand même
à qui ça dit quelque chose margaret
thatcher aujourd'hui et puis là depuis
janvier c'est vrai qu'elle nous récite
le catéchisme sarkozyste on a une
carrière on a eu aussi le travailler
plus pour gagner plus
c'est une martingale qui a gagné en 2007
donc il ya 15 ans 15 ans il s'en est
passé quand même des choses dans la
société depuis 15 ans peut pas faire
comme si rien n'était arrivé le problème
c'est que les républicains ils n'ont pas
analyser leurs défaites consécutives de
2012 et 2017 ils ont considéré à chaque
fois qu'ils ont été volés par françois
hollande élu d'un concours de
circonstances et par la sphère fillon
vous souvenez qui leur a fait perdre la
victoire du coup ils n'ont pas vraiment
revu leurs logiciels pour reprendre une
expression un peu consacré un peu cliché
et les voilà donc sur leur refrain
préféré donc on a un rôle sur les
fonctionnaires haro sur les assister
haro sur les banlieues haro sur les
immigrés alors on peut dire ça peut
rassurer parce qu'après tout ce sont les
colonne vertébrale de la droite ce sont
ces valeurs mais moi je vois pas comment
ce cocktail qui a déjà été refusé par
deux fois par les français en 2012 et en
2017 finirait à l'usure par les faire
gagner au delà du programme sur la
stratégie et si l'on changeait de
stratégie non parce que je trouve qu'à
se vide programmatique s'ajoute un vide
stratégique la droite elle à la fois
pressurer est divisé alors les pressions
l'a10 entre l'extrême droite et la
majorité elle manque cruellement
d'oxygène parce qu'elle n'a pas su se
renouveler layette deux grand mouvement
de recomposition qui se passe en dehors
de ses murs la droite identitaire elle
se réinvente chez zemmour d'une certaine
façon on verra ce que ça donne
la droite la droite libérale elle se
réinvente chez emmanuel macron et
possiblement edouard philippe qu'est ce
qui lui reste à droite classique aux
républicains rien des miettes et divisé
elle l'est bien davantage que ce qu'on
voit sur les belles photos de famille on
à la ligne dure celle d'eric ciotti ou
la droite de la droite comme vous
l'appelez comme vous voulez wendling
terroir qu'on pourrait saisir celle de
gérard larcher on aligne cateau celle de
bel ami on a des lignes social pour
chercher un peu encore d d d incarnation
de cette droite sociale est pour
l'instant ses divisions elle reste
discrète parce que c'est le temps de la
campagne bien évidemment mais en cas de
défaite ce sont ces axes lac qui feront
éclater la droite et même en cas de
victoire ça risque de faire mal car il
faudra bien que les républicains
décident avec qui il scelle pour
composer leur majorité il faudra qu'il
fasse ses choix qui la feront
probablement éclaté irish folk et
casques et si on se projette qu'est ce
qui peut être le mieux placé finalement
pour recomposer
les droites en cas de défaite
j'ai envie de dire tout dépendra des
scores de des résultats de la
présidentielle des ça change tout
imaginons qu'une vanne ou pas et grèce
se qualifie au deuxième tour avec un 17
18 19 % on peut dire que l or a réussi
une partie sont parés l'heure pas réussi
son pari puisque elle veut être
président de la république mais elle
aura réussi déjà une partie du pari est
quand même très important après avoir
elle effacera je pense pas du tout la
même chose que ce que nvidia et que dire
matthieu croissandeau je pense au
contraire qu'il ya plus tôt il ya plutôt
sur le plan programmatique une réelle à
la fois un réalisme économique important
j'ai importé économique est important
c'est vrai la seule chose sur laquelle
je suis d'accord c'est que si on gagne
il ya une pressurisation nouvelle qui
vient en fait de la république en marche
la pressurisation de l'autre côté de
l'extrême droite elle est là depuis très
longtemps et ça fait très longtemps que
la droite essaye de trouver son
ajustement il l'a fait dans le passé le
fait qu'aujourd'hui une partie de des
thèses économiques de la droite soit
reprise par par emmanuel macron de
paille l'amérique
non
une partie je pense aujourd'hui qu'il ya
néanmoins des choses à faire pour
particulier quand on regarde et l'état
des finances publiques on peut dire
qu'on veut sans qu'on s'en fiche mais en
réalité on ne peut pas et c'est
d'ailleurs là dessus marine le pen 3 un
jour qu'elle nous explique comment ils
financent ces mesures elle dit toujours
ça va être sur la fraude sur
l'immigration on va récupérer de
l'argent non à un moment il faut être
sérieux de vente représente à présent
ciel il faut savoir financer les mesures
qu'on avance alors je reviens à votre
question 6 imaginons un candidat theiler
s'en sort bien dans la présidentielle
mais qu'elle échoue elle sera je pense
quand même en capacité de porter de
porter les couleurs pour les
législatives et elle ira et on verra ce
que ça donnera mais je pense qu'elle
sera en capacité à le faire si
un peu comme bellamy lors des dernières
européennes
elle échoue avec un mauvais score la
chance qu'à la clr qui explose ça paraît
assez clair ça veut dire que plus à
l'est on attendait ce risque là ils
existent pour partout il existe aussi
pour l hérault m imaginez quel héros m
que du manute ben maintenant soit battue
au deuxième tour qu'est ce que devient
un problème derrière oui effectivement
mais
puis la question la majorité aux
législatives qui se pose pour
la team intermittents là dessus le vrai
sujet c'est la recomposition de la
cartographie politique derrière avec
quand même deux nouveaux venus qui vont
compter vous allez avoir reconquête qui
est quand même un parti structuré avec
de l'argent avec des adhérents et donc
qui va vouloir exister dans les
territoires et ce sera la très
intéressant et beaucoup plus instructif
que la présidentielle et puis vous avez
horizon parce que on n'en parle pas là
puisque ce sont les présidentielles et
que edouard philippe et toujours dans la
maison commune mais mais là le vrai
sujet de recomposition centre droit
libéral je vous rappelle que dans le
lancement l'ordre dans les comptes
l'ordre dans la rue c'était edouard
philippe c'est un slogan qu'on entend
aujourd'hui par la bouche de valérie
pécresse mais le 9 octobre edouard
philippe a fait son sa structuration de
discours de lancement d'horizon là
dessus donc ça ça va être absolument
passionnant la recomposition et
l'émergence de nouvelles forces
politiques
il y aura beaucoup de choses à voir ce
sera passionnant jusqu'au lycée relative
et après et notamment pour ce sens
public merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat jérôme
sainte-marie rappel le titre de votre
livre bloc populaire une subversion
électorale inachevé c'est aux éditions
du cerf merci encore